The cell radio in your device
operates roughly like this.
>From an initial idle state,
it takes a couple of seconds
to turn on, until it
can start transmitting.
That kind of latency makes
for a sucky web browsing experience.
So rather than going back to idle,
state machine stays on at full power
for a certain amount of time,
typically around five to ten seconds,
before dropping to an
intermediate low power mode
that uses less battery than full power,
and has lower latency
to return to full power
than the standby mode.
If a new transfer is initiated,
the radio will be promoted
back to full power mode.
And if nothing happens
for another period of time,
typically around
30 seconds to a minute,
it'll drop back to standby.
The exact latency in tail times
varies between carriers,
and even within carriers
between states and countries,
as they try to balance low latency
with longer battery life
based on factors like cell congestion,
and typical or prevailing
network conditions.
So if the exact timings vary,
how do we optimize
our transfer frequency?
Ultimately, it doesn't matter
what the specific timings are.
You just need to understand
that the network
is going to attempt to balance
low latency with high battery life.
For us, when it comes to
planning out data transfers,
we'd really like to be
somewhere around here.
Now if we return briefly
to the cell radio state machine,
we know that every time
we perform a data transfer,
the radio will stay active for at least
another five seconds of full tail time,
and anywhere from 30 seconds
to a minute at low power
before it finally returns to standby.
That means every time
you initiate a transfer,
you're powering the cell radio up
for at least 20 seconds.
So let's take a look at how
that affects an app,
using the little cookie approach.
An app like this
can drain the battery
without even having
to transfer much data.
Each of these small peaks
is an app pinging its analytics
back to the server.
In this case, every 15 seconds.
These larger peaks represent
intermittent data transfers
based on user interaction.
For example, they may be viewing
a restaurant listing
or looking at tomorrow's
weather forecast.
Beneath it, we've graphed
how this affects the radio state.
The blue shows active data transfers.
The red, the radio in full power.
And yellow, showing low power mode.
The gaps in between, if there were any,
indicate when the radio was idle.
So while this app is running,
what is the percentage of time
that the cell radio is able
to go back to its idle state?